merci françois noël tu viennes rappelé
les chiffres ils sont édifiants et ils
posent leur jeu peut-être prioritaires
majeur premier de la question du
regroupement familial regroupement
familial son origine ses 76 c'est aussi
une conséquence directe de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et de
son article 8
qui dit que chacun a droit la continuité
de sa vie familiale mais c'est
aujourd'hui et je le dis en saluant
notre président je suis confus de
intervenir au moment où nicolas sarkozy
arrive en tout cas je profite sa
présence pour l'heure le remercier pour
son courage il a fixé la la ligne de
notre famille politique sur ces
questions avec beaucoup de force et en
sortant des chemins couru pour démontrer
qu'on était présent et que c'était nous
qui portons cette responsabilité face à
ce défi majeur de l'immigration d'avoir
des solutions responsables audacieuse
courageuse et et novatrice il en faudra
sur cette question du regroupement
familial ont rejoint ce que disait brice
tout à l'heure c'est la question de
notre capacité à décider qui on veut
accueillir et le regroupement familial
aujourd'hui
eh bien nous prive quasiment de choisir
ce que l'on veut accueillir puisque
c'est une conséquence quasi automatique
qui résulte de cette convention
européenne des droits de l'homme et qui
résultent de mesures aussi qu'ils
limitent ou qui contingentes ce
regroupement familial alors d'abord il
faut dans l'esprit de ce que viennent
souligné guillaume pour apporter une
première réponse dire qu'on ne peut pas
tolérer et accepter de façon automatique
mécanique que chacun puisse venir en
fonction de ce regroupement familial il
faut qu'il y ait un contingent chaque
année un plafond un plafond qui dit
qu'on ne peut pas autour
et même s'il ya les critères pour
l'année 2015 ça sera reporté sa sera
étudiée y aura une liste d'attentes mais
qu'on ne peut pas autoriser tout le
monde à venir en permanence tout le
temps il y a ensuite des mesures
techniques sur les conditions de revenus
de la famille qui accueille de celui qui
va faire venir son conjoint ou ses
enfants
ça c'est le regroupement le
rapprochement familial
c'est la personne qui épouse en france
un étranger qui va faire venir son
conjoint français qui est pause qui
épouse une étrangère ual inverse une
française qui épouse un étranger ça
c'est les deux tiers parce qu'on appelle
l'immigration familiale aujourd'hui à
leurs groupements et il y à le leur
attachement donc pour ces questions il y
à des mesures techniques que nous devons
prendre par exemple la durée de séjour
du regroupement de celui qui est déjà en
france aujourd'hui ces 18 mois on peut
monter il faut monter à deux ans mais la
vérité nous oblige à dire qu'il faudra
aller bien au delà il y à la question du
revenu du regroupement pour dire qu' il
faut qu'ils aient la capacité
d'accueillir la personne de sa famille
qui va venir il y à la question du
logement il faut que ce soit un logement
salubre
il faut vérifier aussi que les personnes
qui viennent exprime la capacité et la
volonté à tout le moins surtout de
s'intégrer à la nation française qu'ils
aient des connaissances de notre langue
de notre histoire de notre culture
parce que c'est à ceux qui viennent de
s'adapter à notre identité à notre
culture est pâle inverse il faut le
réaffirmer très clairement
dans tout cela
si on rajoute la question qui a déjà été
évoqué tout à l'heure celle des
prestations sociales dire très
clairement qu'on ne peut pas verser les
prestations sociales dès le premier jour
d'arrivée sur le territoire national
pour rompre ce modèle 4 activités
sociales
quelqu'un qui vient en france dans le
cas du rapprochement familial
et bien il faut qu'on aime pose une
durée 5 ans par exemple pendant laquelle
il n'y aura pas de prestations sociales
parce qu'il ne faut pas que la venue sur
le territoire national soit lié aux
prestations sociales
je prends l'exemple de l'australie
l'australie la france et 10%
d'immigration économique
c'est 50% d'immigration familiale
l'australie ces deux tiers d'immigration
économique
à peine un tiers d'immigration familiale
et il y à une modulation sur les
prestations sociales
donc toutes ces solutions elles sont
techniques mais je conclu françois noël
pour dire aussi que ces mesures
techniques ne seront pas suffisantes il
faut très clairement posé la question
aujourd'hui de notre capacité à
maîtriser nos politiques nous ne pouvons
plus le faire dans le cadre de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme telle qu'elle est rédigée
aujourd'hui et il faudra très clairement
avoir le courage de poser la question de
la renégociation de la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme pour
retrouver notre capacité de maîtrise de
nos politiques
merci